so uh you mentioned your real name at
the beginning of this episode
yeah my name is agnes is there anything
would you say it like that
my name is you're saying it like an
android my name is agnes
for the record not even my family calls
me that it so that's why i also didn't
come out with it because
it was guess yeah but like
what is there like anything else i mean
i guess we're just going to dedicate
this trash taste to like
new things that aki's never said 107
things you didn't know about hockey
dearest
oh god uh okay i don't even know where
to start i mean like
i was mentioning earlier i could
probably talk about the fact that i was
in military school for like or
military class for like four years and
what is that
yeah what what so it's called nj rotc
navy junior reserve officer training
corps
and it's damn that was drilled into you
man yeah how many times did you have to
repeat that
what's the purpose of this it's when you
want to go into the military and so when
you want to go into the military
yes to fight for their country
um but yeah i noticed that's a very
american thing it's yeah because like
i i feel like it's very patriotic yeah
it's very patriotic because in england
nobody talks about
wanting to go to the military yeah i
feel like i almost died themselves in
there
i you rarely hear about kids who are
like 15 16 who want to go in the army
and yeah that's their parents
in it right right yeah so it i remember
when i came out on twitter i was just
like oh you know because uh my mom had
showed me like a
like this old photo album and there was
one of me in high school in my dress
blue so
sorry that's the term for the uniform
and um i was like oh [ __ ] you know what
i never
actually came out about that and that
was like a huge part of my life
what age do you start that uh when the
moment you hit high school you can do it
so what what'd you have to decide to do
that or your parents are saying i did
because you from age like 14 yeah you
like decided i want to join them
so i did not join so no no no no okay so
my reasoning for joining wasn't exactly
for like the most patriotic reason it
was because uh
had a crush back in high school he he he
was part of it and then he was like
oh yeah uh like it's pretty cool in here
and then i joined and it didn't work out
but i stayed because i actually started
to like it
um actually join the military to impress
a boy
yeah i know right it was weird so when i
came out about it on twitter i had like
this huge impostor syndrome no one
expected that of me but
like you're not like so you can join
this thing but you're not like you don't
have to join the military no well
okay so the one in that i took in high
school which by the way uh mine was
actually the strictest in the entire
country this isn't just me saying it
like it you can look it up but
like when you can join military if you
want and you get credited more like when
you join
rotc in university or go to military
academies
um so it's like an extracurricular yeah
but if yeah basically
um but you get credited really well
especially at the one that i went to
how many hours a week would you do for
it well
the average high school student has
eight classes rotc
is part of that schedule plus another
one so i had nine classes
so so what'd you have to do in military
school oh god um so
a lot of people have misconceptions that
like you have to learn how to fight and
use a gun or whatever but that's not for
high schoolers
was it like super strict you have to
wake up at a certain time so it's a very
disciplining thing it's not for everyone
a lot of people
um get out in their first year i stayed
for all four um but basically
like so you have like once or twice a
week you have to wear your uniform and
yet it has to be completely perfect they
look at every crease and fold like you
had to iron it well
like every time i i put my hair up in a
bun they had to check for a little fly
away so that should have to be like
gorilla glued down you know
which i did some gorillas which i didn't
do you saying this makes
so much sense because like we obviously
we hang out like
outside of this and i think this has
caused me to have the biggest resting
[ __ ] face ever
i'm like there will be certain moments
where you go into what i call
akimon mode yeah right where you know
everyone else is a [ __ ] monkey and
then you're just like
there and you're just there to sort [ __ ]
out yeah it's when something goes wrong
it's just like okay
mum mode activist yeah yeah like what
are you doing what are you doing i'm
gonna sort this out i'm gonna sort that
out yeah yeah yeah
hearing this makes so much sense now she
walks into a room and it's like there's
not enough discipline in this room
it's time to slap it so like so the
program i was into it's an extremely
disciplining course and you get credited
a lot
back if you go into university what's
like a typical day uh so
in the school you have to like go
through inspection so you all march
outside and then you stand at attention
and you have to just like
you have to learn the art of not showing
any expression
and then you have to sound off uh like
so someone comes in front of the drill
inspector
and then instructor and then he asks you
a question
and then you have to yell it in his or
her face and say sir ma'am and answer
the question that he had
if you stutter then you get chewed out a
lot like so you
it's a very disciplining thing they're
like like so for example
um in front of me like you would [ __ ]
your pants every time
like when it was inspection first thing
in the morning so if i had a girl in
front of me
i'd be so nervous i'd say like good
morning sir and then she'd chew me out
a lot chewing out as in like screaming
oh yeah yeah
chewing out is the term that we use when
you're getting yelled at a lot yeah
so um oh and then along with i don't
know if any other
uh rotc course ever did this in high
school as well but
um i did train also for four days every
year um at usmc united states marine
corps
in san diego and that's with real drill
instructors where you have to
go into the barracks you get pushed so
bizarre yeah i know i'm telling you i
had a huge big imposter syndrome and i
can't believe i never came out about
this on the internet
but um yeah because it just completely
goes against your personality
i know it's like i told you there's a
whole different part of my life that has
nothing to do with it because all
all i think of when it comes to like
military classes like you know that's
seen in [ __ ] full metal jacket
yeah yeah the dude's just like [ __ ]
yelling at me i honestly thought to make
a video of me reacting to military
movies and like rotc movies just to see
if they're accurate enough
but like yeah um ex-military
professional oh yeah
like so i'll just tell you this like
that being at usmc
uh you're never gonna get like more
verbally abused than like having four
marine instructors and yeah yeah um so
what when did you decide you weren't
gonna join the military oh oh
that was because if you completed all
four years i guess how many
like what percentage of the class that
completed four years went on to join the
military
wait oh like oh everyone that enlisted
like how many
like how many how many ended up going
into the military she went to the
military
i'd say like at least like maybe half
yeah
like yeah it was 50 50. because the
thing is it's like when you're in this
program
it's like four years you figure out you
don't like it well no because like you
know people join this program not just
to join the military it's because it
looks very good
on your resume so like you can literally
do a lot of things just by saying that
you even did this in the first place
because
it's literally like not for everyone
it's like doing like you know duke of
edinburgh right yeah but it just looks
good on your resume yeah
that's what they said yeah that's what
they said i'd say like when you first
when i first joined um every friend that
i made i'd say i like i only had one
friend left by the end of it like and
you know um did you enjoy it you know
what you feel actually a sense of
accomplishment when you do it especially
you sound like you enjoy it
no no no things i enjoy
so like if when you're in it like every
day of your life you're like [ __ ]
your pants like not wanting to get
yelled at and it's like i really hope i
don't [ __ ] up like shining shoes and all
that like
and just the physical and mental like
why people would want to do this
it's because it makes you because you
toughen up
and i feel like people are a lot
stronger there's other ways to toughen
up
i feel all right it's it's a little
experience yeah it's a learning
experience and i feel like in any other
situation people would call what i went
through
abuse but like you go in like and with
the possibility of going to the military
and you have to be strong
so in order to do that you're pushed to
your limits i've met some people who
joined because they felt like they
needed
someone to like guide them like tell
them what to do
yeah and get that [ __ ] together pretty
much and it's not for someone who
doesn't like being
told what to do i can tell you that uh
obviously yeah
and the actual uh marine corps base i
remember like you'd wake
uh you'd be yelled at for like pretty
much the entire day then you go to bed
at like midnight and you get to sleep
for four hours and that's the only time
of peace that you have to yourself and
that four in the morning
uh the drill instructor is like come
banging on the door and then they like
rip your sheets off and then they tell
you to get up and you have to stand at
attention but you're like all dizzy and
stuff
and then by the time i uh i ranked up to
chief petty officer which
i guess it's just high ranking i got to
be one of the people to chew out
uh other like cadets that would have
been fun
you know what i feel so satisfying
so yeah i went through like three and a
half years by this point being yelled at
and then now you get to be the person
to yell at other people a bunch of
psychopaths
so basically like we'd have like our uh
our um
i guess our like a platoon later uh we'd
be lined up in front of the door of like
our assigned cadets
and then she'd like whisper and count to
three like and then on three you all
have to like smash the door and
get open and then just you basically
like [ __ ] kool-aid man essentially
yeah that's essentially what i did and i
made a few people cry
at that so i'd like so proud
because like it's so unexpected uh when
you first meet him and unlock course
trauma yeah
we've got three cries in here yeah no i
don't want to see your
medals or achievement how many people
you may cry how many kids you make yeah
so no that i don't know it was a
learning experience and again it's not
for everyone but once you're done like
you're always proud that you did it
that's that you know what that
equivalent is that's the equivalent of
like you know being like
the the youngest in high school and you
having to like wait for the seniors to
go on the boss
yeah and then when you become the senior
you're like out of the way i waited five
years for this [ __ ]
that's exactly what that is all i'm
thinking is you must have really [ __ ]
liked this boy what
i mean like you know i was a freshman i
was like 14 or 15
so yeah but still even even if there was
like the goal of my dreams and she's
like
finna go to the army you want to come
i'll be like i'm good
i'm good i wasn't really like
told properly like how strict rotc was
and i didn't realize that we were the
strictest in the entire country
but then but you were yeah but you would
have figured that out like first couple
of times yeah but then i started the
person who's like i'm gonna do it and
ask questions afterwards
no i am and when i when i was
experiencing it
like i stayed because i was like i don't
know i actually really like this
what did you like about it i don't know
because like it's really pushing you to
your limits to rank up
you have to do well in academics and you
have to do well in physicals and you
have to
completely like pass it with flying
colors if you want to get to the rank
that i did
which took four years so you say you got
into this because you liked a boy
yes was that was there like a point or a
moment when you like in your first joy
isn't it
when you just like when you just had
this realization of oh [ __ ] this is what
i've gotten myself
into [ __ ] me oh yeah no that was like
like in the first day
i feel like and yeah you were like four
years easy i feel like without people
like you we wouldn't have raves because
you know you're the kind of person who
would turn up something like well i
guess i gotta do it now
no one likes the rave when they turn up
and i just leave but oh it's funny when
i was 18
i'm committed i'm here now what's funny
when i was 18 i actually held a rave
that was during a very different hockey
time
where my house what you held up raving
your house
would would execute me yeah if they
found that american pipeline